and so it it makes us narcissistic
almost because we think the whole world
revolves around us
[Music]
but the same thing of what empowers you
also makes you blind because even though
you think you're being empowered but
then when you're not getting wiped by
the man that you want and he goes into
the real wild world and you realize I'm
actually very regular Digger I'm nothing
special
okay
but what class of women are you talking
about like how intellectual are they
where do they come from what all women
or are you think all women think like
this most women yeah
would you think they think they're about
I think yeah because you get the dating
app data which allows women to be very
honest and women only swipe right five
percent of the time they're not ugly in
pictures though no women find 80 no no
women find 80 of men unattractive not uh
okay like unattractive but what about in
person no just anywhere anywhere yeah 80